hi everyone uh thanks for joining my
talk my name is gocheng and today i'm
going to talk about our recent work on
addressing data efficient machine
learning with meta learning prison
language models has gained a lot of
attention in the nlp research community
and also it helps
obtain better performance on a lot of
downstream tasks but this is at the cost
that we need to have a lot of labor data
for example in this plot i'm showing the
performance of a phantom bird model on
this qqp data set which is a sentence
similarity task and you can see that
actually in order to obtain above 80
performance we actually need more than
300 starting examples so this is clearly
not the case for a lot of
actual applications or domains there
where we only have a very limited amount
of liquid data in this work we try to
look into the auxiliary information or
which is so-called proxy supervision to
help tackle those tasks here and these
different signals can come from either
noise labels or automatic labels or even
like human rules
and these are typically much easier and
easier to collect than those manually
annotation data so how do we leverage
such data and our idea is that we're
going to use method learning to model
and transform such data and the key idea
is that with the different type of data
available and we're going to build a
meta model to transform those data such
that this can be used by our task model
let's take the
example of using week's revision as as a
case here on the right hand side i'm
showing a general framework of how we
can use method learning to leverage this
data for example we are given a set of
small um clean examples and also a large
set of approximate
examples here and our goal is to train
your task model and the way we do this
is that
in addition to our the main task model
we are also building a so-called meta
model and in this case this is a labor
correction network which takes the
noise data
and tries to produce a corrected label
and this graphic label is going to be
used by the main task model to train so
without the direct mapping between the
noise labels and clean labels here
there's no way that we can tell how well
this metamodel is trained here the way
we do we do this is that we're going to
take the training main model and
evaluate its performance over this clean
data so such that this loss of
performance can be
used as a feedback to backpropagate to
update our metamodel here so this
essentially um boils down this entire
framework to this by-level organization
process which is also very similar to
classical medium learning so essentially
in the outer loop we're going to
minimize the loss of the trained model
over this small set of clean data
whereas in the inner loop our main mode
is trained to minimize the training loss
over this transformed data from the
metamodel let's take a deeper look into
this framework so in this plot i'm
showing the uh detailed architecture of
this um framework for using math
learning to uh to
leverage correct labels here on the left
hand side this is the label correction
network which takes the noisy features
and also its weak labels as input and
tries to produce the critical labels
here now our main task model is taking
that as data and showing its own
parameters and then the main model is
evaluated over this small set of clean
examples here and this entire loss can
be used
to update our meta parameters here and
the inside we're using here is that we
believe a good demo correction network
is able to produce better
credit labels such that the main model
can benefit from that and so that it can
produce a better model which can
perform well on this clean set here so
how does this perform in that
evaluations here so we can do
experiments over different datasets
including both text classification and
also image recognition
across this broad set of data sets here
we compare with two
classic methods one is to also use
method learning to assign different
weights for importance to the examples
in the weak set and the other way is to
leverage
level correction but it's based on
estimating the labor corruption matrix
based on the two sets of data and you
can see that actually with the proposed
data driven approach our method is able
to achieve better performance in terms
of leverage and supervision to improve
the task performances
and beyond just working with manhattan
learning with wix provision we also
extend this work onto multiple settings
including how to use this to model and
leverage data from a different domain or
different language also how to use this
to leverage enable data
with that there's still a lot of
challenges going forward and also
questions announcing here for example
one thing that we can do is settle to
understand like uh what is the best data
sources
for this millennium framework and also
to understand to which extent that this
framework can help us in transforming
data here and also how to make this
framework to work with even more complex
settings like structure prediction or
generation here
and the other factor is that
because of methane methanol in nature
the computation of this method gradient
requires approximating to these second
order gradients so efficiency could be
an issue for some cases
and also recently there are some like
new training paradigms involving
reinforcement learning and also problem
learning how to best combine the method
framework with such training paradigms
to achieve a better performance is also
interesting direction to go here and
also in order to better evaluate such
models
having benchmarks available like on this
visual notion of exploration part will
also be very valuable to the rich
community there so i think that some
pretty much summarizes my talk um thank
you for joining my talking also thanks
to all my collaborators um in all this
work and if you're interested to discuss
more please feel free to reach out to me
offline thanks